I'm wondering about fear of success
because I know that that also is
something that people think they don't
have but it's a huge thing because
everything around you would then change
people treat you differently maybe
people would be fearful of you or
envious of you yes it's terrible to have
a lot of money no motive in a gated
community I know it's a terrible art
part if it is and mythos of a golden
door here I am you know I have bad
thoughts are you with my mom you know
I'm not a good enough person but if I go
through the golden door everything will
be changed and wonderful now I go with
my hair in order and all going to be
great and it's this fear of this great
transition and something that you can't
come up to or people be waiting for you
to fall and there are people who from
envy wait beautiful but if you don't see
life is this you know if you know that
you always fall on your face but just
that you are who you are and you're just
struggling on a slow you know uphill
struggle always be downs but you can
come always fight your way back up I
think some of that that fear is that you
the publicity machines create an
unrealistic vision of who you are when
you're me right well like you're
suddenly a celebrity and you're this
different person and no you you're the
same schlubby person but you write well
you know it I wanted you know mom's a
little bit because there's several
things about this part of fear of
success I think is fear of scrutiny
because the moment you're on the world
stage and the spotlights on you you're
very worried that again as I'm saying
you could falter you could fail etc but
the good part of it is that first of all
you get paid very well and that's very
nice and but you have to make sure that
the money doesn't rule you so in other
words you it's a good idea to keep your
overhead low so that you don't have to
take every job that's offered to you
we've turned down more work than we've
taken because we that allows us first of
all to learn new skills it also allows
us to follow our own creative bent
whether or not it's immediately
lucrative so we're not ruled by money we
keep our overhead low but also there's
two hollywood's there's a Hollywood of
awful materialistic neurotic crazy
people who are destructive and toxic and
bristle and they get a lot of the press
and there's another Hollywood equally
real
that's composed of people who are
wonderfully talented creating amazing
work they come from the heart they love
their families they go home they're not
crazy and they're doing it for the right
reason
each Hollywood is equally real and those
kind of people are all up another food
chain so what you've decided is first
which Hollywood you want to belong to
and secondly which Hollywood you want to
exemplify you want to be and and so what
I do what I've done my whole career is I
gravitate toward a good Hollywood so
when I started writing The Twilight Zone
companion I was calling some chronics
Rod Serling's attic I was literally and
I was interviewing all the people who
worked with him and I was seeing what
great people they were creating great
wonderful work that changed the world
that made people better in you know then
I wrote the book with guillermo del toro
and one of my mentors was Ray Bradbury
so I was deliberately choosing people
who first of all I could learn from but
secondly who should reinforce my belief
that you could be a good person you
could speak from authenticity you could
be kind and compassionate and that would
not destroy your career in fact it would
make your career better you had a
greater chance of succeeding by being
authentic by being genuine by being
loyal and honorable and if you were some
kind of Hollywood snake again I think
some people believe they have to turn
themselves into monsters to succeed the
exact opposite is the truth and I think
that that's a very hopeful realization
because you don't have to betray
yourself or other people in order to
succeed but there is a definite fear
among people that they're going to be
found out you know if you if you're
doing really really well we'll find out
you're really not that good yeah and you
know and that really terrifies you
blowing what if I found out but it
sometimes it is one burden to know that
that's what most people feel where
they're going to be found out no matter
how firms are in our house for how long
they're eventually been acquired out for
not being that amazing well but again
this is what's so useful to interview
these is hugely successful people he's
wonderful brilliant artist you just see
what happens when they have rejections
when they have disappointment there was
a there's a there's a guy who um he
wanted be a writer and he wrote a script
and he sold his script he had his first
big sale to the network's and so he went
from the travel from Ohio to New York to
have
first meeting with the producer and the
director and all the actors around the
table and he dressed up in a suit and a
tie and he had a briefcase and he went
in to meet with them and the meeting
went really well they said everything
just right and the meeting came to an
end he shook their hand and he's headed
for the door and he was so nervous that
he missed the door walked into the wall
and dropped his briefcase in his
briefcase sprang open and his socks in
his underwear spraying out so lesson
lesson furiously blushing furiously he
gathered up the aula socks me and there
were put them back my bouquet stumbled
out into the corridor in the hallway and
thought to himself how can I ever face
these people again and the producer came
out in the hallway and put his arm
around this young writer and he said
look little friend all they care about
is what you have up here and the writer
was Rod Serling and that was the first
experiences enough in the hit in this
industry and so even rod had those
moments you know and of course he became
one of the great writers one of the
great show runners and he didn't know he
didn't know he died at age 50 and in the
last interview he gave the reporter said
do you think your work will will last
and he said good writing like fine wine
has to age well with time and he said I
think my work has been momentarily
adequate so he never knew he never knew
that Twilight Zone was going to be one
of the great great shows ever made well
the greatest shows every age they would
last and it'd be even more popular now
than when it aired so it's really
dangerous to aim for great you just say
I'm going to do the very best I can
until the deepest truth I possibly can
and just see what happens
yeah well what you have control over is
what you create well you don't have
control over is how it will be received
you don't have control over whether
whether it will last you don't have
control over people whether people will
appreciate it all you can do is say okay
what's my truth you know rod rod used to
say when he about his own writing he say
is this the truth as I know it or better
yet as I feel it well that's all we can
do really and all we have is our
authenticity all we have is our truth in
our story I wish one I always said
actress is nice to coach you know actors
it was like what is your most important
job with the first job and he all kind
of manages and I said well no your most
important jobs to tell your truth yes to
tell the truth of your character
whatever that is and because that's what
people will connect with and share and
and that's where we go out of the you
know out of the theater is feeling a
little less alone and a little more
connected because we recognize the truth
if you're not telling the truth there's
a real disconnect there was a television
show with the showrunner and they were
dealing with a very painful subject
which was sexual abuse of children
adults adult survivors and and I was
watching this clip of this show and it
felt completely bogus and I thought and
I thought well it's important to have
this on television because people tend
to feel very isolated by these kind of
ugly incidents but but if you have it in
an exploitative fashion then it's the
opposite it has the opposite effect
doesn't make people feel more connected
or less shamed it makes people feel more
isolated because it's not their truth up
there and so I was quite offended by the
show not the topic but the way in which
was handled and I said what research did
you do for this and that oh well we just
thought we could imagine what it would
be like and I felt now said you know and
I was really clear in this show and so I
mean the truth is very very important
and if you don't know the truth and
you're going to present what you want to
be the truth we better you better
research it because this isn't a joke I
just know what you're talking yes you
always your audience you're being given
a great privilege to speak the hundreds
of thousands hundreds of thousands
millions of people it's a great
privilege and if you lie well shame on
you you know it hurts people also you
know this guy was very very successful
and so it's not our responsibility
whether or not someone else succeeds or
not whether their worth is deserving or
not it's our responsibility to to tell
our truth to be to do our job that's all
we have control over you know and and
then and also it's very important now
what's a game you can't win so for
instance if you're pitching a story to a
network or studio and that's not what
they want to make then the question
ultimately becomes how committed are you
to what you want to do because at the
end of the day you have to decide what
you're going to create and and if you
say okay
because you know as I said we meant for
many many many people and we've done so
for many years and most people give up
at the slightest resistance and it's
very important if you're actually going
to create something worthwhile to have a
backbone you look and say okay look
someone once asked me the secret of my
success and I said I don't give myself
an out that means that if I say I'm
going to do something I have to do it
then and sometimes it's hard and
sometimes it's harder but it's
irrelevant if it's hard and it's just
what I take on and I'm committed to
doing it but it's also exhilarating it's
so much fun I love what I do
you don't want to ever hear somebody say
well they won't let me I don't know
today is yeah but but if if the imagine
if I might dimmer yes but but if you
know buyer a doesn't want it well do
your research and find buyer B and buyer
handy what does who is good with that
kind of time will help you hit say well
but also in the old days you know when
there were only three networks and would
cost millions of dollars and you had to
shoot on thirty five-millimeter then
there was an excuse if like for instance
Orson Welles in the last 20 years of his
life he never got to make a movie well
that wasn't his fault he was trying hard
it was just so expensive he was in an
art form that was crazily expensive but
nowadays when you can buy you know I
mean everyone has a camera in their
phone for God's sake if you want to make
something make it you know I'm in this
and they're also the question you know
if you want a career in Hollywood and by
Hollywood I mean sort of this world art
form that we work in you have to say
well what am I in it for am I in it
because I want to be rich because I want
that Hollywood dream of the big house
and the limousine well that's one dream
it's not my dream god knows or is it
that you want to create something to
share with the world
well this it's the latter then anytime
you say well they're not letting me do
it it means that you're just letting
them stop you and you're not saying okay
what skills do I need to learn well who
do I need to affiliate with what if you
decide that you're going to greenlight
yourself then you're free but but of
course you know if you say they won't
let me do it then you've got you good
excuse yes and the question always is do
you want to live exclusive you on within
be in the action you know because and
again you know it's not for us to say
what someone else should do but it's up
to us to anything attempting yeah but no
but it's up to us to be authentic and if
we inspire others that's great if
someone hears any of what we're saying
and says well gosh let me take a crack
at this let me try you know and and you
know if you try and you keep trying and
you find the way through the door then
you know you usually do quite well there
was another friend of mine who um he
decided he wanted to be the greatest
writer who ever lived
true story and he went to a psychiatrist
and after an hour of talking about this
stuff the psychiatrist said to this
young man he said well I think I can
cure you of his delusion so you should
come see me twice a week and my friend
left that session and decided instead of
doing that he would just go for it and
that was Ray Bradbury and he became of
course one of the greatest writers the
writers of the 20th century everybody
told me that story he was my mentor for
over 10 years and so so again one man's
delusion is another man's great
accomplishment and what determines that
often is just the drive the drive you
know I think they once told me that his
life was the story of someone who
decided he was going to go somewhere and
went
you